one other thing donald stressed was so
important guys was a whistle yelling for
help won't get you very far but people
can hear a whistle you can catch all of
the desert survival tips we have put
forward this week by going to our
website go to eightnewsnow.com for all
that this was a very fun five-part
series because i learned a lot
a lot a whistle that's so it's
inexpensive and it can make it that's
what i said and you wouldn't i think a
lot of people wouldn't think of that you
think obviously the water and the tools
and the kids most importantly about that
is the whistle for your kid because if
your kid gets lost they just whistle the
whole time there's no batteries you can
use a whistle and then they'll be able
to hurt so i bought one actually on this
one for my dog and the yoga mat you cut
and with the safety pins all those are
good tips yeah you don't do any exercise
you might as well just do it
start to use whistles to make sure we
all make mic checks yeah that's a good
idea right now
just blow the whistle find brian someone
in the newsroom this weekend it's gonna
be a great weekend it's gonna be hot
though i love this shot this is actually
our new eight news now weather deck
camera and i could scan the horizon with
this all for my computer this one
getting a great shot right now of the
win and encore how about this past week
temperatures should be right here in the
high 80s right but look at we've been
lately since sunday 83 and then the 70s
for a few days 69 yesterday and then 70
or 69 should say wednesday and then 76
yesterday this just felt nice
but now we cranked up the heat a little
more alright 87 centennial hills 86
spring valley 89 for north las vegas
that also includes downtown 89 also
whitney ranch and green valley 89 for
you and henderson
also 89 southern highlands that seems to
be the popular number right now
mountains edge spanish trail at 85 that
includes our friends down rhodes ranch
two outside the valley here you go 78 up
there and rachel 97 death valley 85 for
you in searchlight 93 for laughing right
now so you're
hot under the collar but even hotter for
tomorrow there's our radar network
nothing going on at all across the
desert southwest we certainly could use
a rain right here where that fire
started in southern california we
certainly need it here all that rain
again is in the pacific northwest
flattened ridge in the jet stream but
that still means we're still going to be
hot it's just it'll amplify a little
later in the weekend and that's going to
allow those temperatures to really crank
up and bring back those triple digits
winds for tomorrow here's the other good
news all right your winds stay light
look at that less than 10 miles per hour
throughout many of our neighborhoods
throughout much of the day your weekend
forecast so like we said tomorrow is
even hotter 97 sunday at 100 our first
triple digit temperature since september
99 on monday so here's the forecast 65
tonight overnight nice evening a mild
morning start at 65. 97 for tomorrow
sunny and hotter after 80s today almost
10 degrees above normal look at that
like we said heating up this weekend our
triple digits we'll be hovering right
around the high 90s and still hot next
week but look at that big changes
thursday and friday we'll show you how
strong those winds will get including
your recreation forecast also coming up
splash pads this weekend guys
going to be very busy it's no weekend
not major wind again until next week no
that's the other good thing a reprieve
we're excited about that thank you ted
all right john tricia joining us now
with